people I've heard this you hear in the
business who likes working for someone
who really doesn't like working for
someone some people in this business
don't have the best reputation your
people love working for you Wow exactly
now I don't know that that's I'm sure
there are days where they're like you
know she's a total [ __ ] but I try and
be fun most of the time we try and do
like group stuff you know like trips but
what kind of trips do you take them on
most recently we went camping we went to
Hamal a Himalayan like it's like three
hours away and we want camping but
there's a group of people that don't go
and usually those are people who are
married with or with children right but
the single people come and then we have
fun you know we'll do mushrooms or
whatever did you do what did you really
do mushrooms I did mushrooms I can't
speak for anybody else I don't force my
employees to do them by the way I just
want to know and the Netflix if you're
watching ok wait everyone should get
this straight cuz my my staff is so
pissed right now is also welcome to join
us no no my stuff gets I'm wandering
James not James the cameraman No
Oh
James has committed half of his murders
while on mushrooms no that's just
unbelievable my staff I make them share
one nutribullet every Christmas that is
their gift you're giving you took them
camping and everyone took mushroom I
didn't provide the mushrooms just for
legal reasons I want that to be stated
very similar we're in the budget is that
is that craft service yeah people can
pick mushrooms in the forest oh yeah I
mean you can take them there you want
real leprechauns and found magic
mushrooms so are you ever afraid because
we're in these times where you have to
be very careful with employees right not
be inappropriate what you're not
supposed to sleep with your employees
anymore that's a no-no anymore well
that's been for yeah but also let me
point out that you're not supposed to
say inappropriate things I'm thinking
Chelsea Handler mushrooms forests a lot
of single employees things could get off
the rails did they I mean they do a
little bit but nothing like no one's you
know it's not off the rails I mean it
depends what you consider off the rails
I think you're off the rails is way
different than my off the rails I mean
my off the rails is like a 2% no you
know I'm going for it no skin today
that's right that's exactly right and
you're just like yeah you don't know
what's up you didn't when you wake up
and you're like where am i and I think
that's a good Saturday morning
[Applause]
you